something crazy happened in Hollywood
did you hear about the Academy Awards
just announced right now if you want to
win best picture to be nominated what
the new guidelines are when they
announced this people lost their minds I
said these new guidelines if we follow
these guidelines the following movies in
the past wouldn't never won an Academy
Titanic Forrest Gump Godfather The Hurt
Locker No Country for Old Men Lord of
the Rings Midnight Cowboy One Flew Over
to Cuckoo's Nest Gone With the Wind
Schindler's List the French Connection
Silence of the Lambs All About Eve
Lawrence of Arabia Casablanca Godfather
2 The Gladiator Dances With The Wolves
The King's Speech I can't let so many of
them according to the new guidelines
none of those movies would have ever won
an Oscar in academy by the way it's as
if they're not paying attention to data
because just in 2014 nine years ago 44
million of us watched The Academy do you
want to know how many people watched The
Academy in 2023 18.7 million it was the
third worst and guess what the top three
Wars have been the last three years why
because when Hollywood goes woke they
lose viewership and Hollywood has
forgotten why it started in the first
place why they left Jersey and Thomas
Edison to go to Hollywood wait till you
hear about the story of Hollywood it's
going to be a full circle coming back
maybe a lot of people in Hollywood need
to watch us to understand how it got
started in the first place if you give
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel but more
importantly if you know people in
Hollywood text this to them let them
watch it and let them tear it apart
let's get right into it so I think
Hollywood has forgotten how the whole
thing got started look when you and I as
fans when we think about Hollywood what
do we think about it I think about the
star I think about the Walk of Fame I
think about the big sign in the
mountains I think about Chinese Theater
Dolby Theater but I think about the hub
for creativity for movies I've been to
these studios I've been to shows I've
been to all of this it's an incredible
place with Rich history but Hollywood
has forgotten why they escaped Jersey to
go to Hollywood here's why early
beginnings of Hollywood 1900s and 1910s
the Hollywood Story began when
filmmakers started moving to California
to escape the harsh patent laws imposed
by ready Thomas Edison his Motion
Picture patent company in Jersey who
owned many patents on a movie making
process and had strict rules and
regulations in place for the film
industry when I think about film I think
about creativity I think about edgy if
you force me to produce a product based
on your guidelines on losing creativity
I don't like it here's what I think
about when I think about creativity you
can't put them in a box right you better
do this or else you can I'm creative
leave me alone right to be creative the
second thing is if you try to force an
agenda down the audience's throat and
they don't show up guess what it's not
working you gotta regroup and go back
and say let them be creative no
guidelines let the audience produce a
product that the customers want to see
Hollywood's forgot about that as well
the Golden Age 20s and 50s characterized
by the studio system the big five
Studios Paramount and Gem Warner
Brothers 20th century and RKO dominated
each with their own roster of stars this
period produced many of Hollywood's most
beloved Classics like wizard of the Oz
Citizen Kane gone with the win
Casablanca it's a wonderful life cycle
and many others then we go into the 60s
and 80s this is the post Studio system
era during this time the old Studio
system had fallen in the new Hollywood
this arrow is marked by films that had a
more realistic and grittier aesthetic
such as Great Escape The Godfather One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest Taxi Driver
alien it was just creative oh man this
this is crazy what's possible if they're
doing stuff like this what could come
next then in the 80s was a rise of
Blockbuster film Star Wars E.T Indiana
Jones Back to the Future Die Hard
Scarface and many others then it's the
modern era 1990s and 2000 this is when
we see movies like Goodfellas Fight Club
The Matrix Pulp Fiction Toy Story Lord
of the Rings The Departed Gladiator The
Dark Knight and many others so by the
way at this time we're not caring about
out how many Middle Easterns are in a
movie I'm Middle Eastern can you imagine
I don't like the Dark Knight because I
think Batman needs to be from Iran what
do you mean used to be from Iran no
let's cast and see who's the best Batman
Okay if that guy's the best Batman let
him be not because I'm upset because
there's not enough Middle Easterns in
there or not enough women or not enough
this I want to see a good film when I'm
watching a good film I don't sit there
and calculate and say you know what
they're missing too many of this they're
missing too much I say what a great
movie I'm not even thinking about any of
that stuff but that's the mistake
academies making today and trust me
they're paying the price for it already
but they're not paying attention to data
then we have 2010s to present increase
in diversity and representation both
them from the camera as well as behind
the camera driven by social media
activism increased calls for diversity
high profile example includes Black
Panther in 2018 Wonder Woman 2017
Moonlight 2016 and awoke remakes of
Ghostbusters in 2016 Star Wars and 17
oceans 8 and 18 American Pie girls rules
in 2020 which many of you probably
haven't even seen this time was kind of
like well we should do this because we
ought to consider having more people in
this background okay no problem but it
was still something that was being
encouraged all of a sudden a couple
events happened that's not called in the
academy to force producers to do this or
else you're not going to be nominated
couple events number one 2015 and 2016
the hashtag Oscar so wide controversy
when all 20 actors nominated in the lead
and supporting active categories were
white this led to a widespread criticism
and calls for greater diversity in the
film industry in response to the academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
implemented change to diversify its
membership then in 2017 with the metoo
movement when Harvey Weinstein was
finally exposed for what he was doing to
corruption and other power players that
were abusing their power against women
of course that had to be exposed it was
something that was necessary but then
that got people to say well what are we
doing about it and a lot of people
started complaining but rather than
finding ways to address the issue they
started putting force and mandates in
Hollywood and when you do that
unfortunately you eliminate creativity
in 2020 21 Hollywood diversity bill
passes California legislature and here's
what it was California's film tax credit
aims to punish projects that don't hit
diversity goals under a proposal from
the governor's office Newsome
Productions that failed to meet the
diversity goal will lose four percent of
their tax credit allocation and a four
percent bonus for Productions that meet
diversity goals the provision is part of
a five-year extension of the state's 330
million dollar tax credit Productions
that receive the credit will be required
to submit a diversity work plan under
which they must commit to hire a crew
that is broadly reflective of the
state's demographics look the way we get
judged in business or in politics is
your policies you come out with if
they're great results should go up
because it's all about data if it
doesn't it goes down it's a shitty idea
I've run a sales organization for 20
some years if I change the commission
structure and all of a sudden sales
Skyrocket and good behavior comes out
great that was a good idea but I've come
out many times with a commission
structure that sales dip guess what what
do you like it or not it's not a good
idea got to figure out a way to adjust
it right California passes this bill in
2021 okay if viewership goes up with the
academies then good idea Newsome but if
it doesn't it's probably a bad idea
again 2014 44 million of us watch the
Academy Awards last year 2023 this year
it's 18.7 he's not helping however let's
see what happened in California in 1920
95 of films being made were based out of
California let's see what it's looking
like today and let's first look at what
states are leading the movies being made
the data that we have is from 2021 at
the top California
574 the feature films were produced in
California number two is New York at 91
Georgia 71 New Mexico 60 Louisiana 56
matter of fact the top five control 80
percent of them then it's Texas 45
Carolina 38 Michigan 35 Tennessee 34
Illinois 33 by the way if you look at
the list Florida it's not even the top
10 list we the entertainment plans on
building one of the biggest media
companies and world doing movies docs
show us podcasts all of that out of
Florida and we're constantly hiring
complete side note if you are looking
for again you got a lot of talent look
at our job openings I'll link below you
can find it more importantly if you're
somebody that's a die-hard value trainer
and you love the value teaming gear this
is by far one of my favorite shirts it
feels so good wearing this shirt but the
new logo of item is on it if you want to
support the vitamin gear click on the
link above or below order one of these
shirts it's sick that's all I can tell
you so let's go back to it California
1920s
95 of the movies made in Hollywood were
based out of California and 30s it goes
to 90 and 40s it goes back up to 95 then
it goes 90 85 80 75 70 65 60 55 it went
from 95 percent to 55 and the more
regulation they create people are going
to leave California to make movies where
am I going with this so this is just
California losing Market sure look what
the academies just announced to make
regulation to be even mentioned or
nominated for Best Picture in 2024
moving forward their guidelines are even
stricter than California's guidelines
all right so here's what the new
requirements include number one at least
one of the lead actors or significant
supporting actors must be from an
underrepresented racial or ethnic group
number two at least 30 percent of all
actors in secondary and more minor roles
must me from at least two
underrepresented groups number three the
main storyline theme or Narrative of the
film must be centered on an
underrepresented group number four at
least two of the creative leadership
positions and department heads must be
from underrepresented groups number five
at least six other crew and Technical
positions must be from an
underrepresented racial or ethnic group
and number six the distribution or
financing company must have paid
apprenticeship or internship for
underrepresented groups
are you already like losing your mind
asking if this is a spoof or satire
article this is actually their new
guidelines and you may be asking Pat
what is considered an underrepresented
group here's what's defined as under
represented group number one women two
people of color three
lgbtq plus people four people with
disabilities five people with low-income
communities six people from rural areas
seven people from indigenous heritage
footage again earlier I mentioned to all
those movies that one Academy is the
greatest movies of all time that won an
Academy none of them would be nominated
according to these new guidelines they
just wouldn't be nominated and they're
fantastic movies and when you and I
watched it we didn't think about why
there's no Middle Easterns in there why
there's no disc in there but today the
rally cry is so big that they want to
change it so what could happen here let
me give you a couple different
Industries to look at our sex the MBA
okay a product that I loved watching for
many years did you know 73.2 percent of
players in the NBA are black you're
doing only 12 and a half percent of
America's black what should we do should
we lower that 73 percent and only allow
12 and a half percent of blacks to play
basketball because we have to be diverse
you know it has to be fair right because
only 13 percent of players are are white
three percent are Latino while nearly 24
percent of America's Latino why don't we
have more Latino players did you only
point four percent are Asian we can look
at a couple others but we can look at
NFL 56 or black only 12 and a half
percent is black but we can look at
Major League Baseball and say well how
about Major League Baseball only 5.6
percent are black players in Major
League Baseball but 31.2 percent is
Hispanic we have one too many Hispanics
playing in baseball we can look at NHL
NHL's a completely different statistic
84 percent of folks in NHL are white do
you realize how ridiculous this is
people are forcing things to win that we
are not interested in and forcing things
to change that we're interested in
nobody watches the NBA and says too many
black players no it's great it's whoever
can perform and win at the highest level
nobody watches baseball and says one too
many Hispanics what is the difference
with Hollywood well why is Hollywood
doing this you know we got to make WNBA
better because we only have 456 000
people watching the WNBA playoffs in the
finals but we have 17 million that's not
fair no people are not as interested in
wmb as they are in the NBA it's very
simple it's called interest you can't
force interest if I try to force
my kid to like a sport he does not like
he's not gonna like it he's gonna hate
it there's no difference between that we
have to be interested in it and
Hollywood unfortunately is trying to
force people to be interested in a
product that they're not interested in
and they're paying a price for it and by
the way if Hollywood has left California
to other states trust me Hollywood will
very soon leave America and do movies in
other states because the world is a very
small place today with the Otts they're
also going to pay a price for it and not
only that do not be surprised if very
some people say I don't really care if
I'm nominated for an Academy Award or
not I simply don't care funds are going
to come out saying we are funding movies
that don't care about winning an Academy
Award and The credibility of the Academy
Award is going to get smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller and
eventually if you're going to be like
yeah I really don't care it's still
going to matter today for the next
couple decades but this kind of strategy
history tells us eventually they'll
either have to Pivot and someone's going
to have to knock some sensors into them
or they're going to say honestly you
keep forcing your crowd to all do this
the way you're doing it we're going
elsewhere it's always been that way if
you're watching this you're from
Hollywood you're pissed off on what I
said I totally get it you don't agree
with me on where I'm at you know
philosophic and all this stuff this is
the only thing I ask you we love the
content you create Hollywood when we
watch you when you're just trying to
play loose and tell a story without
Force when you force we don't like it
that's how simple it is and by the way
making movies is one of the most
effective ways of telling stories and
changing people's perspective by choice
not by force if you do Force you're
going to lose an audience if you do it
by choice we'll follow you anyways I got
another video I want you to watch you
may not like it if you haven't liked
this video do not watch this next video
if you've liked this video You're Gonna
like the next video it's a video
directed to people from California I
would warn you because it's going to
trigger many of you who are emotionally
attached to your great state of
California state I love that I lived in
for 24 years if you've never seen it go
watch this if you don't want to be
pissed off and you are emotionally
attached I'm telling you avoid watching
this video anyways you got value from it
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel take everybody bye bye
foreign